[Music]
I've been surprised by all of it and
I've been very gratified by the response
that I've gotten from someone who people
Anthony Rapp is still reeling over the
impact of his sexual assault allegations
against Kevin Spacey since then several
other men have come forward with their
own allegations claims Spacey's lawyer
has denied I hope that everyone who's
dealing with these sorts of situations
does feel the courage to come forward
Monday a house of cards sixth and final
season will resume production early next
year without their leading man I don't
want a version Robin Wright who starred
opposite Spacey will reportedly take the
reins meanwhile rap took to Twitter to
wish the Netflix show his very best it's
important to me that you know that the
ripple effects of everything's gone on
don't negatively affect too many people
so I'm really happy that the people were
working on house of cards are continuing
to get to do that work I think that all
of this is an important step to help
dismantle the machinery that allowed
this sort of thing to continue
[Music]